[Music]
welcome back to the gym good to see you
guys this episode is brought to you by
me on these cool super cool super soft
underwear delivered right to your door
all right guys hundred percent
satisfaction guarantee you can get 20%
off and free shipping on us by going to
meet undies comm slash jenna julie new
designs every month is a limited offer
guys check it out while you can
longtime sponsor the podcast and equip
equip the toothbrush system for you guys
clip is it's a really awesome innovative
innovative way to have a toothbrush that
is not gonna run you dry in your bank
account starts at just 25 dollars and go
to get quick calm /gen and julian right
now you eat your first refill pack for
free with the quip electric toothbrush
that's your first pack of refills for
free okay go to get quick comp slash
Jenna Julian or click the link below
thank you guys sponsors hello everyone
Wow another crazy week in the books huh
yeah this month well it's over now March
is over but it sure took us for a ride
yep I'd say yeah I can't really I'm
sorry to be far away from my microphone
I'm just feeling like well I'm glad that
marches over honestly this whole month
sucked for us but like I feel like you
know I've done a lot of you know talk
school appearances that kind of thing
where one of the most common questions I
get asked is like how do you not let
sort of negative comments get to you and
that kind of thing and I feel like this
week I am being defeated by comments
like you know everybody goes through
these moments of like I don't know
whether it's your just like emotional or
something but like I just feel like
comments have been getting to me a lot
and it's
like I'm trying to decide whether or not
I'm just being sensitive at the moment
or like what's going on because it's oh
man like okay for example our hamster
add not an April Fool's joke passed away
on Friday and it was devastating for us
like we loved our hamster so much and
that was really hard we have a really
hard day and we brought him to the vet
and they confirmed he has passed away
and we it was just it sucked like you
know we're crying and like upset we miss
our little guy and you're still having
these moments of like
you know he's a hamster and he had a
good life and we gave him a great life
and all of that and for the most part
everyone has been really really sweet to
us we did have a few trolls being like
he's just a hamster like you know you
don't need to be upset which we expected
because you know people are insensitive
but like I think it's where we all have
the internet right like everyone has
access to just boundless and limitless
information whether it be correct
information or wrong information or
whatever we're all just flooded with
information constantly so I feel like
often times comment sections turn into
this like know-it-all sections of like
everybody suddenly is an expert in
everything and Julian literally just
posted a vlog of him talking about it
because I had tweeted about it because
it was just really sad and I didn't want
to like make a video or something about
it you know it just felt insensitive
because we loved him so much but like we
do need to acknowledge that our hamster
has passed away which is really sad and
hard and we don't like but then you know
there were some comments like
particularly one comment in there that
just really [ __ ] pissed me off and it
just like reminds me how like the best
and the worst things about the Internet
is that everybody can can be here you
know yeah it's like the best part of it
and just the worst
and we just like I've read this really
insensitive comment that was just like
critiquing it first of all it was a PETA
article of some poor port grandparents
that were like our grandson has had
three baby hamsters that have passed
away in a couple months what are we
doing wrong and it's like obviously
there's endless reasons like
maybe using the wrong bedding or like
cuz can he drink his water you know what
are you feeding him just like basic
stuff and I was like this it's just
really insensitive man like to insinuate
that that we weren't taking good care of
him when he was clearly an adult hamster
when we got him and we didn't know that
or think that but like the vet confirmed
he had died of old age but like to think
like someday if one of the dogs passes
away and then someone's like well here's
some things that I think you might have
done wrong with your dog I'm like can
you not can you [ __ ] not those
comments in general are hard and most
times you're able to brush it off and
continue on not giving a [ __ ] but add
work just pass away man yeah and it's
when you're the emotions get tied into
it yeah I feel emotional yeah and we're
emotional and like you know losing had
like Jenna said is what it was a hard it
was a hard thing to go through
particularly for me I think it was a
hard thing to go through because I had
just lost a friend and so now it's like
all of a sudden so much loss and so yeah
when you're raw and you're feeling a lot
and you know you're kind of we've had an
emotional night yeah you're you're
you're in the thick of a lot of emotions
that are really intense so comments like
that I feel like are just are just
really shitty and there's there's not a
lot of brushing off that can be done at
a time like this so yeah well and men I
don't even know it's it's like it's a
whole ad thing and we had had him
confirmed by the bet that you know when
an animal is so little like that it's
easy to be like oh my god what did I do
wrong like did we do something did he
get into something is there something
we're not seeing is there some sort of
mistake that we made like my first
instinct was to be like oh my god what
did what did we do like what happened
you know but after we got the
confirmation that he was just like an
old guy yeah and I was like oh my god I
guess we we never really thought about
how old he was when we got him and you
know it felt really sat into us cuz we
had had him for 11 months but he wasn't
11 months old you know
which even if he was which he 100%
confirmed was not 11 months is close to
a year and their lifespans are one to
two years that's 2 to 3 or whatever one
wanted to have some one-two-three
two-two-three 2 years whatever but like
Pete like just so everyone knows like he
passed away we brought him in to the vet
they confirmed you know like they
confirmed that he like not there was
nothing wrong like he you know they
would have found certain things if he
had been injured or something yeah it's
like regardless its shitty to have have
have to read comments like that and like
I think I think you're right and I think
also like dude you don't kind of tell me
about these comments during times of
emotion like I I had comments on my
video right where I explained that my
best friend had killed himself and
people were like oh god this dramatic
kid again and I'm just like I don't know
what to do with that like I don't know
how to react I don't know what to think
of it I don't know how to brush it off
you read a comment like that when you're
going through something like that and it
is bad it is just a bad time and that's
it we had posted something like I don't
know if obviously all of you guys have
been through losses in two different
degrees but like there's only so much
like crying and things that you can do
in mourning and thinking about it before
you like even during portions of that
mourning period you're like I need these
moments of like laughing and remembering
and like trying to be happy and remember
good things and just as a person you
know what I mean and after like a week
or something you had posted a we were
cooking or something and there was a
comment on there that was like wow
shortest period of grieving ever
what a joke LMFAO like I actually like I
want to fight you verbally I want to
fight you like what what what do you
want
Julien to do or anyone to do in that
position like but you damned if you do
damned if you don't it's like people
want to judge your life they want to
judge how you react to things and this
is like this isn't a [ __ ] TV show
dude this is me documenting my real
actual life [ __ ] that you don't document
every day and we're trying to use it as
an outlet of like I'm just trying to
like cheer myself up sometimes
but like you beyond that to like its I
just feel like a lot of it is you know
there I go through periods of when
things sort of get to me or upset me and
think times when they don't and for the
most part everyone is really really kind
and understanding and like as a normal
person and understands that we're also
normal people you know but like I the
other night we're playing video games
and I'm I'm looking at this Twitter
thread of people I screenshot at it
because it made me so upset like I get
these comments a lot where people
speculate whether or not I'm pregnant
and like I get it and it's not the
comments that are like oh my god I hope
you guys have kids I'd be so fun if you
guys had yeah it's completely goes those
are different comments to me those are
really sweet and I appreciate you guys
and it's the other ones like this is a
thread of people in my most recent video
where I'm dyeing your hair and they're
like wow she's really cleverly hiding it
with that that sweater tied around her
waist and like that kind of thing and I
just like this this podcast is not meant
to be this but this is how I feel I just
feel like everything is sort of getting
to me like I know people who have had
abortions who have had miscarriages who
have had stillbirths
and I am fully disclosing to you that I
have not had those experiences but I've
seen other people go through those
experiences and it is absolutely
heartbreaking and got wrenching to watch
them go through that and I know that you
guys for the most part are being you
have good intentions with us but like to
think if I had gone through a
miscarriage or something like that and
I'm seeing people speculate you know
gleefully whether or not I'm pregnant
meanwhile I'm over here being like you
know at my wit's end like grieving the
loss of something a person you know like
I just can't like that kind of thing is
the kind of [ __ ] that I feel like would
make me sign off the [ __ ] Internet
well it's it's hard to not feel
completely defeated and and when you're
your most vulnerable or your your
getting insulted in the most horrible
way yeah by people who are just happily
doing it anonymously like cowards and
the problem is it's like most of the
time we're able to surround ourselves
with you guys the happy ones the
wonderful the positive
yeah the treatment people yeah and like
you know we we we have so many
experiences where we're in like a good
place and you guys are wonderful that we
sometimes forget that the majority of
people who saw us you know sign on the
internet to come in to YouTube videos
and it's streams and whatever and tweet
things are there they're cancerous and
they're toxic and it sucks because they
have no regard for a person who's behind
the avatar who is tweeting something
it's just like I'm gonna spread my
judgmental angry the comments
speculating if women are pregnant or not
and I feel like this is a societal thing
like a cultural thing like we see it as
this fun guessing game of whether or not
people are pregnant and I just I find it
to be insensitive I think that it
shouldn't be a thing that we do anymore
like growing up I used to see all those
magazine covers in the grocery store of
being like is this person pregnant like
for my I want to say the tabloids yeah
yeah my entire youth was spent debating
whether or not Jennifer Aniston was
pregnant and like how torturous that
must be for someone to constantly just
be like I'll let you [ __ ] know you
know what I mean like what's the point
like I get it sells magazines because
people want to play like it's coming
from a good place but just like being
exposed to people that have infertility
issues is like it's really insensitive
you know and I just don't think that
that should be a thing that our culture
deems is appropriate
like if someone if someone is pregnant
and tells you that and is having a baby
like go be happy for them but until then
the speculation process I find is
something really insensitive you know
what I mean yes I know exactly what you
mean I'm not trying to like you know
chastise anybody and I will share with
you like we would love to have kids we
need to do a few things first but like I
just think it's really wrong to do that
it is it is it's [ __ ] up and it it
bums me out that those comments show up
yeah it sucks man getting to me lately
yeah it's hard it's hard like like I
said you know normally when we're fully
equipped with our
barrier of protection from the the bad
part of the internet on our everyday
life it's easy you just you swipe it
away but when you're going through [ __ ]
you don't really necessarily have that
barrier because your guards let down
you're feeling a lot and it's just 100
times worse I know and I feel like again
I feel like most of them are coming from
a good place with this with the
exception of the comment of you having a
short grieving period according to opera
which I just feel like is an uncalled
for comment but the ones about like oh
well here's here's an article that I
found on PETA that's completely
unrelated to your hamster dying of old
age and and how you should have cared
for him differently is like I think that
that's a product of everyone being an
expert and everything all the time and
again I find insensitive and the the
pregnant comments is like I just think
is you know something we've been
conditioned to do this fun guessing game
of whether or not people are pregnant
but I'm saying I haven't had those
experiences where I would sign off the
internet because I'm so [ __ ] hurt and
upset by them but I imagine that there's
plenty of other women on YouTube that
have had miscarriages or infertility
problems and people commenting like I
don't know how old these people are or
their their experiences with women and
fertility issues but like when you
comment those things like she's
definitely pregnant I can see it like if
that person had had a miscarriage or was
really trying to have to conceive that's
the kind of thing that would send a
person just into absolute like crazy
town like I can't handle it I can't read
it
you know what I mean like that that
would make me want to or or you had just
had a miscarriage so what are your
choices you have to sit on the internet
and tell everyone and describe your pain
and how much that hurts you and how
upset you are and or you just get to let
people keep saying things like that like
if you if you had just gone through that
experience and then someone's being like
she's definitely pregnant I would cry
and lose my [ __ ] mind are you kidding
me
that's really shitty right it's a really
shitty thing to read it is I'm just I
guess it's just a cultural statement on
our part that I feel like it shouldn't
be a thing that exists we shouldn't do
that to women ever you know yeah
I think tabloids get away with it
because they're so far removed from the
actual person but on a YouTube video I
mean I'm not saying either one's right
or wrong but on a youtube video it's
like that you know we post a video we
read the comments were right there yeah
you know what I mean like it it would
suck to be a movie star and read and
walk into a grocery store and see your
face like that would suck yeah and
that's horrible
but like it happens so much more
immediately to a youtuber to someone on
the Internet and that it's just it's
just shitty man it's just shitty I just
saw and I'm sorry that you had that
comment I'm sorry that you had this it
was a thread of comments it was a group
of girls discussing why don't guys from
women that's literally hiding my
pregnancy like Plus also even if like
there's a grace period in there where
like you you you wait a certain amount
of time before you even tell family
because it's personal and yet intimate
and horrible exactly like you have to
trust that people on the internet or
celebrities or anyone like would tell
you there was that big circus around
Kylie Jenner being pregnant and even
that I was sitting there being like this
kind of sucks for her you know no one no
one is putting themselves in her shoes
nobody yeah like it really what it must
feel like to be going through whatever
the [ __ ] it is you're going through that
you're keeping private because it's your
life yeah and you have the world like
accusing you of let you know XY and Z
non-stop brutal man yeah I know and it
does like the the tone of the comments
to seem of this like fun guessing game
you know and it's like she's definitely
like I get a lot like I had this
conversation with ela on the h3 podcast
where she's like yeah I get you're
glowing you know all the time I'm like I
wish I got comments like she's glowing
it's always like she's definitely put on
a few I I definitely think she's
pregnant she has a sweater tied around
her waist I'm like oh so now you just
calling me chubby fam like [ __ ] off you
know what I mean like in no way does
that ever make me feel good to read
those and you are not getting any bonus
points for guessing if someone was
pregnant like I don't get it I just
don't get it
yeah it comes from a really cruel place
ever it's not a cruel place it's a good
place these people are trying to like
you know they're happy for you they want
you know but like they don't understand
the potential or maybe they haven't took
the time to understand the potential
harm that could really cause somebody by
saying that you know it's hard to know
why people leave certain comments I
don't know even if they're not in nature
hateful like not thinking through what a
comment for the hamster comments I feel
like it's it's it's a vast level of
information that's available to everyone
so suddenly everyone's an expert and for
the pregnancy comments I think it's just
people being excited and and wanting
something without realizing that that
your person that comment could cause
potential harm yeah because I'm I'm not
saying that I'm so upset that I want to
sign off the internet but I could
imagine a scenario where that would
drive anybody just to the point of like
I don't want to share my life anymore
yeah that's the type of thing that you
know I said it today on the vlog and
I've been thinking this and feeling this
for a lot of months now but a big reason
why it's hard for me to vlog as much as
I used to and post consistently about my
life and about my day as I once did is
that it is very very exhausting to put
yourself out there and regularly have
people judge you and your choices that
about how you live your life and even if
you know most comments which they are
positive it doesn't really matter
because all it takes is one to kind of
like stick with you and then you're just
like it's in the back your head and
you're thinking about it as you live
your life and all of a sudden like
comments on the Internet are affecting
your choices and about how you're going
about your day and that is that is a
horrible horrible feeling it's a
helpless feeling it's a feeling where
you think to yourself how did I get to
this place I didn't sign up for this I
you know I thought this was a positive
documentary experience I didn't realize
I was I was gonna be judged so hardened
and have it actually affected me because
most times doesn't affect you but it
really only takes those those handful to
really you know and it's tough because
you know in my time being on the
Internet there have been many videos
that I posted so many videos or
something happens whether it's something
serious whether it's something traumatic
whether it's something even not even
that bad and and a comment will appear
that that really reminds me that like
wait a minute like this is this isn't
all just a group of people who are
supporting me in my life this is these
are some judgmental people you know who
want me to feel bad for something that
I'm already trying to go through in my
life you know what the people coming to
my house video where I said don't come
to my house I mean there are there were
a significant amount of comments on that
video saying hey it's part of being a
youtuber deal with it idiot I know I'm
like that that sort of thing is like
it's super upsetting to be like so many
people just and also I understand that
argument I understand that we put
ourselves out there so we are open to
criticism we are open to judgment and
those things and we're not saying that
any of it's unfounded it's just it takes
its toll sometimes that's like I'm not
saying I didn't sign up for this because
I know I did absolutely but I understand
that argument and then I also understand
the argument of people being like just
because I put my life out there doesn't
mean please show up at my residence you
know what I mean or just because I put
my life out there it doesn't necessarily
mean I want to read comments all day
every day of whether or not you think
I'm pregnant you know like there's a
difference between being open and
understanding of criticism and then just
you know getting some really unfair
criticism where you can't always say
something back without like oh well that
guy's just a dick we're like [ __ ] that
girl she's a [ __ ] she put her life out
there if we want to guess whether or not
she's pregnant or call her fat we can do
it all day you know yeah like okay you
can but it's also like you could just be
a normal person and be relatively
respectful you don't feel like us you
don't have to follow us you have to do
any of that where we're open to your
criticism I feel like we've made that
pretty clear as well in the past - but
it's like some of it borders on just
like really insensitive we're having a
moment this week guys were having a
moment I think it was just it was it was
some of the add comments that really got
to me because that is still so like
fresh and new you know yeah like I miss
him and we loved him so much and I was
like I'm so proud of you that you have
access to a Google search engine but
like
is really hurtful we did everything we
could Fred yeah he did
and if someone said that to me about one
of my dogs when they pass I'm just like
I I'm so like [ __ ] you [ __ ] you yeah
but anyways Real Talk though if I if I
was pregnant I would tell you when it's
an appropriate time we're not trying to
[ __ ] keep anything secret no but
until then you're not harming me it does
get to me sometimes but I feel like
there are women out there that you could
really harm with those comments like
really harm with those comments yeah and
probably already have probably already
have anyways yeah we uh our plan for
this podcast was to play snake oil cuz I
tweeted out if you guys wanted a third
installment of snake oil and you guys
said yes overwhelmingly so
wanna play some snake are we gonna make
sure that we don't have like doubles
well I went through I went through and I
we might have a double or two but I went
through it and threw out some of the
cards that I recognize this [ __ ] game
man like I didn't think that this is
gonna be like this so if you're new
around here snake oil is the game where
one player picks a profession and the
other player picks a random item made of
two words that are completely randomly
paired and then the salesman has to sell
that fake item to that fictitious
fictitious person yeah but Julian's
really good at it I'm not good I'm the
best sorry for the serious intro I'm not
I'm ready to play let's do it
who do you want to be first no do you
want to be that get this up in up in
your mouth then oh yeah I'm gonna get
nice and close to these mics or else
they don't sound sorry
do you like the whole time okay shade
for shade fair enough do you want to be
the salesman or this Celie you tell me
Sally since you're the best at this game
alright why don't you be the hot
we what are the the professor profession
randomly yeah but they're double side so
yeah I know but okay you know what what
you're already happy and then I choose
three of those and I get to choose
that's how it works
three yeah and then you choose or you
just pick one these are these are these
are the hold on these are the items that
were selling I know that but I thought
in the past we've done it so like we
picked one so that you're not just stuck
with like a ring if they're bad you can
replace it but you don't take three off
the bat okay I got it
right sure what what do you have to give
them to me
what do you know how this game works
you're the person I'm selling to are you
a Salesman two of those cards oh okay
okay sorry all right
I'm confused I forgot I thought I picked
this one in that one and what is your
profession I'm a sports fan all right
when you're a sports fan you got to
watch your team huh they play every
Sunday slash Monday slash whenever your
team plays on a regular basis what are
you doing I was looking at that card
that someone had handwritten a
straight-up [ __ ] on to that's a that
was one of my custom ones okay I'm sorry
I do not know what's going on here just
take a step back I think you're a sports
fan I'm a sport and I'm selling you on a
new product okay that I've invented okay
with my bare hands as a sports fan you
get your jerseys you get your hat on you
meet up with your boys and you goryeo's
and you get ready to watch the big game
every sunday slash monday and because
you were a real sports fan you got
season tickets don't you I can see it in
your eyes I can tell you've season
tickets but that means you have great
seats right you're right up on the
action you're right behind the dugout
not missing a beat and if it's not
baseball
you're not behind the dugout you're
behind something else but you're there
yeah you have a jersey for every
different player on the team even the
ship ones because you're a real fan a
real fan but a real fan is also a real
person you're not a machine you cannot
sit there for ten hours and not move
- like were some games take a long time
yeah so you get up you got to take a
leak
you walk up to the bathroom walk up the
stairs and it's the bottom of the ninth
but you really got to take a leak
there's a long line there's a long line
of dopes out there who don't even care
about the real game they're just there
for the hotdogs and the beer but you
need to get back to your seat to see
this game you do not have all the time
in the world to wait in line to use the
toilet okay you have to use your toilet
card that gets you first in line and
every toilet because if you get to a
bathroom and you have to wait you're
gonna miss the rest of the game but not
if you have your toilet card you walk up
and you flash it to everyone and it not
only blinds them completely so they
can't see so you can just cut them in
line but but it is the one of a kind
there there is one item I am selling one
of a kind one of one we've made one you
are the biggest sports fan in the world
so we're gonna sell it to you we did
beta testing and over a hundred people
who use the toilet card really loved it
and they're currently using it and this
is the only one ever so don't I don't
question my math okay I'm selling you a
toilet card okay there are currently
thousands of people out there using this
exact item they're all duplicates but
you have the only one in the world
okay well it's free at first
oh no it's free at first okay but when
you buy the toilet cards when you buy
the toilet card half of your season
tickets now go to me and they fought
they fought they basically create
inventory for my side business seat card
which is another business I'm working on
it's actually an app where I steal
people's season tickets and redistribute
them for cash so the first step here is
you sign right here and you buy a toilet
card and we'll discuss the deets later
but if you see me in your seats just
don't worry about it just get another
seat and shut up about it too please
so I can congratulations you've been
awarded you already sign you have been
awarded the only one on earth but
there's thousands of other people so
many other people are currently using
this
it's blown up over the last year's I
have had 500,000 downloads in the App
Store and I don't even have an app if
there's thousands of other car yeah how
are we all gonna get to the front of the
toilet look bottom line is you have the
toilet card you get first in line I
can't speak if you run into another
toilet cardholder that's a situation
that I am not equipped for if you could
please like leave me alone about that
I'm scared of it but you are the only
one with a toilet cart so you shouldn't
have you should probably shouldn't have
to run into that scenario right now if
you sign up you get 10 free toilet cards
in the mail over the next 10 years
erratically take my hand and you will
have no doubt it would be first in line
this is not this is this is not a
real-life toilet cards is not Herbalife
there are just our sister company
wherever life sign up and we just give
just okay I'm gonna give you this toilet
card you can get in front of any toilets
the toilets there will be an Herbalife
consultant actually a higher
representative one level above you and
all you got to do is corrupt a bunch of
your friends into giving you more money
and then you can keep your toilet card
you have a trial period congratulations
Tyler card we are Herbalife absolutely
not absolutely not I'm not shaking
marble wants a hug do you want a toilet
card sir he doesn't he pees in the grass
when you pee in the grass there are
other dogs that are also peeing in the
grass wouldn't you like to be there
first have a toilet card sir do not sell
my dog gonna strap it to your harness
every dog will run away from you as you
please he doesn't want it look at him
yeah he doesn't want any of that either
we need more multi-level marketing
harness for us no do not sell my dog
here toilet guards no one is buying it
we don't want it I'm gonna sweeten the
deal here no I'm gonna sweeten the deal
here no listen the answer is listen you
had
like jump in front of the toilet line I
don't know how why you had to make it
it's terrible could you will you ask
I have legally have to tell you if you
ask I wasn't gonna tell you can you
listen I just wanna say we're a travel
agency no we are you take the caller
card and you can go anywhere you want it
works for every airline because the
toilet card is a universal toilet Honore
card that means you can get in any
toilet with no questions asked which
means you can get into airplane toilets
this feels like it would be something
useful for like disabled people or older
people or pregnant people like sure know
everyone everyone yes only one person
have it and we have selected you take
this toilet card you walk right through
TSA don't even blink get into the
airplane
no and you sit on the toilet you wake up
you're in Abu Dhabi congratulations on
your free vacation to Abu Dhabi oh you
want to go to Florida after that you go
to Florida Oh CA got me one of those
Chipotle cards that said you could get a
free burrito bowl or whatever if you
show your chipotle card cuz that was
like the big thing and I felt like
everyone had one and ca was like we'll
get you one I was like oh my god that
would be amazing I literally never used
it because I was too embarrassed do I
look like the kind of person that would
flash a toilet card and go use the
toilet in front of someone else we're
working on an implementation to put this
in your contact lens so all you have to
do is look at some hundreds of thousands
of people are currently testing this
exact thing but you will be the only one
with oh I don't want to shake my hand no
it's not sold I suppose a gentleman
would call it quits here absolutely not
but not a toilet card salesman because I
am NOT going to quit we will give you
your own airplane our pilot as wentest
pilot school for a couple months still a
beginner
[Laughter]
all right toilet card isn't for you but
we'll be back next week to remind you
about this opportunity and we'll be in
your email we're actually already in our
email we already are we have already set
up camp in your backyard we're sharing
an office here thank you for the office
you failed I know I can't believe I
didn't sell some times I got to know
when to stop you couldn't you could have
made me a viable pitch I wish that
Herbalife topic didn't come up that is
such a skeleton in our closet here at
toilet card we don't like to talk about
the Herbalife thing all right yeah all
right I'll be a taxi driver and you pick
one of these off the top two of them no
magnitude all right I'm a taxi driver
I can't this isn't you can pick more so
Julian how much how long you been a taxi
guy 40 years you know the city in and
out what city are you in New York
Wisconsin it's a new city that you've
made so you have a little thing that
that uh you know describes you you like
that while you're driving driving your
meter that describes the fair and you
know there's a thing on the back of your
car it's it's guy so you know if we're
going to from the airport it'll be a
flat rate or whatever yes um
have you ever gotten in a dispute about
how much your passenger owes you or if
there's a tip or anything every single
time I ride there is a dispute okay it
was never clear cut I don't know why
people don't know why
my god costs well instead of ever
getting in a verbal argument why not
stress physical why not stretch out
America's legal system even thinner by
refusing to ever talk to anyone about
your fears in demanding that they fill
out a doubt paper oh ok so how does it
work
explain the doubt paper so you just say
like first of all you make your taxi
like beautiful it looks like the cash
cab on the inside there's lights you're
ready to party then in order to make
some extra cash because you're sort of a
scam artist a little bit I mean in
training we know you you own Herbalife
part-time I recently sold it to myself
for tax purposes
um you drive them a few extra blocks you
charge them a few extra dollars but when
they go to argue with you there's
already signs inside of this party cab
like in the back that says you agree
that we will not dispute this verbally
you will fill out a doubt paper so see
that because they're excited to get in
so are they sitting in my cab is that
consenting to the doubt paper
do they have to physically sound
something no they get in so you're
selling me a sign to put up in my cab
no so when the sign just discloses that
they're already into it so then after
you drive them six blocks around into a
loop-de-loop in there like sir where are
we going
you're like shut up point to your doubt
paper you're selling me a legal trap
here yeah exactly are you are you a
lawyer do you have a law background
because I don't I'll buy a legal trap
from the right guy here but I don't want
to just buy a familiar one how well is
this worded and how small is that fine
print steps but you can you can drive
them anywhere and they have to pay for
it you could drive cross country let me
play you a little scenario here say I'm
hungry
but I'm not working that day say it's a
Sunday I'm hungry I want pizza I want
some good old Wisconsin New York City
pizza I hop in my cab I pick someone up
and I drive right to the [ __ ] pizza
joint because I want them to buy me
pizza is there a clause in there that
gets me free pizza um no sorry we can't
do that but they will have to pay for
your transportation to the beautiful can
I say say that say the ride would have
been ten dollars but the pizza would
have been seven can I charge them
seventeen dollars only if you drive
around an extra seven dollars worth but
that's literally what I'm doing now
you're saying you're saying I Drive
seven dollars worth get seven dollars
that's what I do for a living yeah but
you never have to get in a dispute with
someone they have to write a verbal
doubt paper out so one gets sent to a
court that it's already very annoyed
with all of your diet papers because
they're the ones all this is to prevent
disputes they're the ones filling out
the doubt paper you're saying that'll be
$70 and they say I doubt it and you're
like well the only way that we did that
we handle disputes is if you fill out
this doubt paper and then the lawyer the
individual lawyer that you keep sending
these to he's already very upset with
you so he throws them all out but these
people have already paid you how much is
it which is what you're selling me and I
don't know how much is it it's it
doesn't cause money it's a lifestyle so
what do you get out of this I guess
nothing [ __ ] give her a ride no I don't
consent even though you can't looks very
enticing
it's good I just had it redone on your
advice I'm also a criminal no I'm an
undercover cop you render arrest
oh my mom won yes hello it's equipment
I got myself a table paper don't ever
ride with me she not win my argument my
argument all right that was a good one
so I guess you sold that one mm-hmm
nah you didn't yes I did no you're in
jail
I'll pick two new ones scamming people
you pick you pick uh I saw that I can
see that through the card nice try dude
except I wrote the wrong sponsor around
here because uh it's meant to say quit
so let's just pretend this all right
well I'm me and ease and you could be to
with me undies right now guys go to me
undies comm slash Jenna Julian and you
get to select from there wonderful
wonderful collection of underwear all of
them three times softer than cotton they
now have socks
they have bra let's they have plain
colors they have designs they have
colors like this that was a nice fun I
have a solid gray parent I wear nothing
but me undies and you will too once you
try your first pair you go to me undies
dot-com slash Jenna Julian and you get
20% off and free shipping okay there's
there's no buckets so simple and you
just do it once and you're gonna want to
get 100 pairs my drawer is currently
filled up with all sorts of pairs they
have new designs every month they work
with all sorts of really dope designers
guys let me just tell you okay me Andes
is gonna change your life you're not
gonna understand how good underwear can
feel until you tribe me undies it's a
limited time offer go to me and use that
comma slash Jenna and Julian get 20% off
start wearing the best unaware of your
life dies you will not regret it
Kermit's crying because of how
comfortable me undies is also guys quip
doesn't say quip guys is is the
futuristic toothbrush system that you
never knew you needed but you do need
okay it starts at just $25 okay and they
send you refills on a regular schedule
because one toothbrush isn't gonna cut
it you need a refill to have the most
effective tooth brushing experience and
quipped does that for you guys it is a
new electric toothbrush that packs the
right amount of vibrations into a
slimmer design and a fraction of the
cost of the more traditional electric to
graduation
seriously starts at just 25 bucks most
toothbrushes don't get do do not get
named one of Time Magazine's best
inventions of the year but quip did
they've combined dentistry and designed
to
make a better electric toothbrush work
quip will even give you oral oral tip
tips or sorry oral care tips hold on
sorry our screen is going back there to
get a better brush experience with their
system right now go to get to quip comm
slash Genet julian right now and you get
your first refill pack for free
guys it's actually a really cool thing
you can travel with it very easily it's
small its compact it looks like it was
made by Apple it's nice if you're
looking for a new toothbrush and you're
sick of spending a bunch of money on the
traditional electric ones or you're sick
of buying a reusable one every couple of
months just try quit go to get quick
comp slash annejulien and you get a free
refill pack with your quip electric
toothbrush or click the link in our
description thank you thank you sponsors
he's tired of sitting on his desk bed
with his desk blanket with his sister is
she annoying you what'd she do to you
you tell me you rat real quick Kermit
rat on her what'd she do to you okay
here we go what's your profession gonna
do one more each right I'm a flat
earther did you write this on you
alright
you can pick other cards or I'll pick
something easier okay yeah okay do you
want me to do these that you've
handwritten I'm a twitch streamer okay
does that work that's what streamer
ticker what okay so you're a twitch
streamer huh yeah you play a lot of
games yeah I imagine that you're very
successful because you're very you know
you have a good rapport with me you look
good
I'm sure you're talented I'm out what
what do my looks have to do with you
selling me something I think you're
handsome
just salesman to sale salesman II you're
saying you're a handsome okay hey
salesman to sales mini you mean customer
I like the way you sound on the mic I
imagine you sound pretty good on your
twitch streams - I do also imagine that
you're sitting there for quite a long
time cuz streams can go hours am I wrong
no you're right don't point it I like
you I want to check you out
I might subscribe to your twitch channel
tonight if so I think why did you bring
the mic closer to you - gulp so I
personally think I personally think that
it's difficult to get exercising as a
twitch streamer because you're
constantly sitting at your desk playing
games for hours on end many times you
get on early in the morning you stream
for a long time you get off and you're
pretty tired you don't really want to
get up and go to the gym it right and a
lot of people don't have home gyms or
even gym memberships you know going for
a walk is a nice thing for most people
going for a run maybe doing some
push-ups but what if you didn't have to
do any of that and you stayed in perfect
physical condition mm-hmm go on what are
you selling me I'm selling you a system
that I've developed a system a system
that I've developed that will allow you
to be perfectly ripped with very little
effort 5 minutes a day mm-hmm guaranteed
by scientists that I've paid from
Craigslist to work and make you fit so
after your stream is done you take five
minutes after every stream and then you
will be completely fit and I know a
twitch streamer like you I know that you
are efficient with your time and you
have a lot of stuff to do so today get
yourself on exercise brick because after
your streams you pick up the exercise
brick and you smash it in everything and
it gets you in shape your lifts all
you're gonna do is throw a brick through
your window till in and you run out
front and then you call the cops and you
say someone threw a brick from my window
and they they send the guys out they'll
get you a new window I've talked to them
it'll be okay
but no
you pick it up again no no the new one
no both panes of glass smash the dog
starts barking you're concerned it's
colder in the house because there's a
hole in it
you're gonna pull less you because this
reaching ripped this is reaching I don't
want to buy a brick destroy my
belongings with it's not a bit you're
selling is an exercise not it right
absolutely this is I don't want it this
is an this is a six foot long sized pod
then you put in your bedroom and you get
inside of it it is called the exercise
brick as an undercover name because it's
currently in beta testing but it's it's
called the exercises brick it's
basically an isolation tank a
deprivation tank but while you're in
there it stimulates all your muscles and
its really really unsafe but it works
really well and our we've had three
clients survived it and those three have
been in the best shape ever and they
survived it you could survive you could
be one of them - nope nope you just you
just sit inside the tank
I don't want it it's called the exercise
brick I don't want it I don't want it I
don't want it it's an exercise brick
someone who's been possessed by the
devil
Julie exorcisms exercise brick it
exercises anything oh my god humans
demons whatever we cover all sorts of
situations no I don't plan on getting
possessed I hope good shake and snort I
don't want it no no sir no thank you
how much does it costs $45 no wait a
second nope no absolutely not I don't
have that kind of money $45 a second $45
no no every second it's where I was $45
I don't want it I don't want it what if
I told you know if I told you know that
we are also launching a line of new
headphones no no no I don't put the
heads on it inserts chips inside of your
ears permanently
that exercises you while you're sleeping
know you're asleep and you're burning
calories no what have you ever wanted to
do 100 pushups in a row no cuz I've done
it son and it was like seven and I
weighed like 13 pounds
no you weighed 13 pounds Oh probably
like I don't know like a normal
seven-year-old weight you do if you were
on exercise brick back then you would
weight better than what a normal
seven-year-old good way okay whatever
that meant for you okay just better okay
when you go onto the scale the scale
reflects any number that you want
we're selling a scale it's a rigged
weight system I don't want it I don't
know how many times that to say no I'm
not sold we will build your house with
these exercise bricks so that every
brick that builds your house that isn't
the walls and the ceiling that you live
in they will constantly be exercising so
they get stronger the bricks get
stronger over time so it can withstand
anything I'm a twit sharing the exercise
bricks are not in fact exercising you
they are exercising themselves so that
becomes stronger over time like the like
the Black Panther outfit you know it
absorbs energy and exercise brick
it makes your house stronger than your
neighbors sign here I'm not signing know
about how about don't sell me something
else how about a tattoo whistle hear me
up every time every time you see someone
who has a tattoo you get their attention
immediately by whistling your tattoo is
to let them they'll come over to you and
guess what the tattoo whistle does come
here let me show you you go like this
and then you have that tattoo also it
duplicates tattoos we have a brand new
patented technology that I have not
patented yet that you can touch
someone's tattoo and then it's yours you
steal their tattoos all their memories
there too all of their memories and
feelings that go into tattoos are yours
now
reach out Pam it's your tattoo any
tattoo you'd like just walk in give them
a hug and then your whole chest is tied
up you you have no no no time no pain
just and no money it's free so all you
do is pay me a weekly investment towards
whatever stock that I need cash for and
you can have the tattoo muscle okay so
the answer is absolutely not
so I'm I'll visit you next week about it
we'll talk about it
please stop camping outside of my house
with your products it's public property
all right pick a thing please try I'm a
hostage
nice no I can't that's like nothing
what's I gotta pick a good one sell me
baby
I can't sell this kind of thing I'm
waiting here with my cash I don't have
anything I'm dying I'm a hostage The
Situation's getting worse
are you ready I'm ready so Julian no
you're a hostage right now currently yes
so unfortunately we can't really help
you but we can help people that might
become hostages like in your cab
business don't reference my other
businesses please I'm going to life in
that situation okay well I mean we can
step in and sort of help you at a you
know a low cost but you're you're
probably in some room that you don't
know it's very scary you're very worried
you're worried about how you're gonna
get out there's blood on the walls
okay that's speaking Russian Ashton
anything my god okay is very serious
your shotguns loading in the other room
oh my god okay
well all I've gotten II for the last
week is milk goat okay you're gonna ask
what kind of milk okay let me ask you
are you familiar with what happens when
you peel a banana and you put that
banana peel on the floor yes people slip
on it and they die exactly
go Doyle exactly but imagine that on a
larger scale okay imagine we could sell
you something lightweight portable huh I
could use it I could use it for when
you're in a hostage situation and you
need to get out but you can't you can't
be armed right when you they're gonna
chase you for weapons for not can't walk
through the metal detector with anything
or else they'll catch me I'm talking
about a verbally activated banana shirt
when in the case of being a hostage you
can say shirt off and all of a sudden it
just slips off it peels itself it turns
into a trap for enemies that have taken
you hostage they'd have slip on your
banana shirt it goes everywhere
they're all dead their necks are broken
you are now free to scream at the top of
your lungs for someone to come save you
is it all is
one-time-use thing or is a disposable
one time how much is it one hundred and
fifty dollars you have to wear it's it's
lightweight it's like long underwear you
have to wear it under your clothes and
rip off my t-shirt no it's
voice-activated one time is it buy one
get one half off no what if I gain
weight and doesn't fit me anymore it'll
always fit you it's made of banana peels
that's not stretchy at all well it's you
know we engineered it to be mostly
technology it's tech yeah it's wearable
pec does it sink to my bluetooth so I
can listen to music out of it it
actually doesn't but it will tell you
your your location on your iPhone it
tells me my own location yeah I'm I'm
always in my location I need someone to
tell me where I am yeah we know that
doesn't solve a problem I think I would
just start rotting and smelling no
because it's not like it's not banana
peels itself it feels like a like a nice
thermal but when you word activate it
it's colorism
turns in tip it is it's like a nice
banana cream color so like you like
yellow mm-hmm got one last question okay
do you believe you know you don't have a
hoodie version no it's just a thermal
but I only wear hoodies no cuz you have
to wear it under your clothes does it
keep you one do you sweating it yeah yes
and yes is there a banana that comes
with it like a proper banana no all
right you're throwing a banana I'll buy
your shirt one banana banana minute
you're supplying me bananas for the rest
of my life thank you so much don't do
you turn around and sell them to Whole
Foods
hello I already got a company that could
use banana flavoring it's called Arab
life work for us oh my god alright I'm
doing one more
I got an on a better one mm-hmm all
right
- on my profession yeah I'm a pro
wrestler
oh it's all about the show as a pro
wrestler you're putting on a show every
night yes I am you were an athlete but
more importantly you are an entertainer
yes there are storylines that are
happening in your show yes with you and
your co-stars and your other wrestlers
that's right and you are out there in
front of millions entertaining tens of
millions globally the story relies on
props okay you need props to
professionally wrestle okay a chair for
instance mm-hmm a chair icon slapping on
someone's back knock him down yeah one
of the most iconic pieces of wrestling
ever right but there has never been a
prop that does two things
Oh God okay I'm ready okay there's a
letter sit there there is a need for
many props but you can't have a hundred
props in a show otherwise who's gonna
carry the props the prop truck isn't
that big the screen okay I'm listening
can you see an instance where you and a
wrestler that you desire would need a
flower to exchange to develop the
storyline between you two in the story
can you see that and can you see that
happening okay
sure you give a flower to another
wrestler okay and then you romantically
involved with them in the story yes okay
but then later on their ex comes and you
need to fight them but Durex is much
bigger than you I'll destroy you with us
bare hands I'm scared
okay weapon okay what if the weapon was
a flower that you gave the beautiful
person because it is a flower sword one
side is a flower to shove in your love's
face and the other side is to stab their
ex in the back oh my god Laur
or the blood dripping from the bottom of
the sword waters the flower we've
developed it's a tube that literally
runs from the bottom of the source loops
all the way back up
sprinkles blood but the flower is
powered by blood it isn't it is an
engineered flower okay
flower sword I'm down honestly you like
the flower sword yeah because I found my
pro-wrestler I could totally see a
situation where I'm giving or if you're
like you still really only one who will
ever have it yeah it's part of my
gimmick so people and shows all across
the world they're gonna be hiring you
yeah we're gonna forever have a job even
if you're you're homeless
and you need to go to like the promenade
and do stuff with it you have a flower
store to its it'll always provide income
well I feel like I could make it part of
my my shtick if I was like had a lot of
decoy flowers that people thought were
maybe the sword but then I pulled out
the real reality yeah so the flower
sword is one of a kind hmm
where we all we did is we just wrote
down the idea so we have to make it but
we'll get back to you but deal deal I'm
done so you'll find it absolutely not
yeah no no no that's how we shotgun we
shook on you giving me a product oh yeah
the first deposits been made thank you
we're gonna get to the designer my bank
account information goodbye Julian you
know my name oh no no you don't know
good luck in your next show
well hopefully have it to you by then
how much am I paying for all this
however much it costs to build a
fictitious item that does something
unspeakable why did you take out a
hundred thousand take account cuz it was
there oh no we'll get it back to you we
promised life savings how dare you well
the flower store has been developed
we're depositing ninety five thousand
backer so it only cost five thousand to
make okay in comparison it's not like
that right great sales tactic guys
threatened them with a horrible scenario
and then take it back but only a little
bit so that the the cost it doesn't seem
is nervous
I used to do that round as a kid like I
would be like I would be like wanting to
like sleep over my friend's house and I
would have to go to my mom and be like
like mom I got to see on my tests and
she was like what that's not good why
did you what happened and I'm like I
don't know it was really hard and then I
walk out of the room okay I really just
kidding I got an a can I sleep at
Andrew's house tonight
oh my it would help my argument it would
like help kind of persuade her because
all of a sudden you go from like a
really upsetting situation to like oh my
god that's so positive and I was all
saying you're shifty it works a lot
you're shifty and shady worked a lot of
times we how old were you during this
yeah goodnight thank you guys for a
thank God thank you for playing you
won't have all of your banana shirts
shipped out to you momentarily for when
your hostage for when your hostage thank
you guys for hanging out and thank you
for being wonderful people yeah we
appreciate you know the guys and gals
who come to these podcasts and twitch
streams and hang out with us all the
time you are all really wonderful so
yeah all right good week you want to
take us out
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]